لا غرابه ان تجري هذه الطفله حافيه في هذا
الجو البارد والماطر انه دفء المكان الذي
ولدت فيه رغم انها باتت تدرك وفي هذا
العمر الصغير انه قد يفقد في اي لحظه هذا
ما قاله لنا سكان القريه البدويه الخان
الاحمر ان اطفالهم يوجهون لهم اسئله
مصيريه لا يملكون لها اجابه احنا عايزين
لنفهم اطفالنا فلا صغار يعجزوك في الاسئله
احنا جيلا فهموا كل مده سياره ما يشوفوا
راحوا يعني ما انت متريح لا في الليل ولا
في النهار للمره التاسعه تضطر الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لتاجيل تنفيذ امر هدم واخلاء
الخان الاحمر الذي اقرته المحكمه
الاسرائيليه
ورغم ان جمعيات استيطانيه وضعت حكومه
نتنياهو في الزاويه قضائيا لتنفيذ الاخلاء
الا ان الضغوط الامريكيه كانت اقوى هذه
المره فهذا التجمع البدوي المبني من بي
صفيح اصبح بقاؤه يعني بقاء خيار حل
الدولتين هنا ممر هنا مركز السلام ليس انه
بيت موجود هنا لانه اذا تم اقتلاع هذه
القريه سيتم هناك بناء المستوطنين قطع
الضفه الغربيه شمال وجنوب الفريق الامريكي
السياسي والامني الموجود في المنطقه نجح
في اول خطوه نحو التهدئه لكن المهمه تبدو
معقده وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي لم يستجب
للضغوط وقرر اقتطاع نحو 30 مليون دولار من
اموال الفلسطينيين فيما يواصل بنجافير
اجراءاته العقابيه بحق الاسرى الفلسطينيين
في السجون ما يهدد بانفجار ميداني في اي
لحظه
تتوقفهم الاطماع الاستيطانيه وتهديدات
بنجافير من جهه والضغوط الامريكيه
والمساعي الاوروبيه من الجهه الاخرى ورغم
كل هذا الواقع الصعب والمستقبل المجهول
ينجح هؤلاء البدو حتى هذه اللحظه في
البقاء على ارضهم من قريه الخان الاحمر
عبد الحفيظ العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه